Let's go to our next call from the four, four,
three area code.
Who's calling today from four, four three.
Hey David.
How's it going?
This is a Lando from Baltimore.
Hey Lando.
Hey, uh, so I'm, I'm a little confused, uh,
going into this, uh, Senate trial regarding
impeachment and I was hoping you might have
a little more info since I had trouble exactly
Googling it.
So, uh, I'm hearing that, uh, Mitch McConnell
and Trump are arguing about how to proceed
with the trial.
And what I'm hearing is that, uh, Trump wants
to extend it as long as possible and Mitch
McConnell wants to get it over with as soon
as possible.
I'm not sure if a source on that, but basically
my question is, does Trump have the power
to do that?
And what are you expecting out of this?
Impeachment trial beyond just what we've already
seen in the house.
Obviously Republicans are going to be how
they are Democrats going to be, how they are
weak and Republicans are probably going to
be very aggressive.
But I'm just curious what your expectations
are and how that's gonna play out.
Work from tries to extend it.
Does he have the power to do so as the person
under, uh, you know, impeachment?
No.
So Trump, Trump does not have the power to
decide how long the trial will be.
Now the thing is true, Mitch McConnell listens
to Trump on a lot of things.
So if Trump says to Mitch McConnell, I think
it would be politically better for me.
If this thing goes on and on and on, then
Mitch McConnell might acquiesce to that and
say, or maybe gleefully would just go along
with it and say, yeah, we're going to make
this thing really long.
Let's, uh, let's do it.
But no, Trump does not have the power to decide
how long an impeachment in the Senate that
is filed by the house is going to be.
Now as far as what the impact would be, this
is the question I've said before, I don't
see any path to the, uh, to a conviction in
the Senate, there are 47 Democrats, 45 plus
two independence.
You need 67 to vote to convict.
Where are you getting 20 Republican votes?
I don't see it.
So therefore it becomes just a PR calculation.
Who benefits from a longer versus a shorter
trial?
What can Democrats do in the trial versus
Republicans to help their cause in 2020 and
to hurt or help Donald Trump in 2020 in his
reelection that it's going to be a circus
in that sense.
And I w we're still waiting to hear what the
parameters are going to be in the timing and
the scheduling.
Gotcha.
So just in your try to consider, I know you
have other colors, but just in your opinion,
what is the potential longest that, that Mitch
can drag it out if that's what he's directing?
I don't know legally what he
can do.
I don't know legally what you can do.
I think it would be very hard to justify it
laughing more than a month.
And my understanding is that right the, that
initially the Senate is keeping their January
calendar clear to account for the possibility
of the trial.
I don't know of any way that it goes longer
than a month and I would assume it's a couple
of weeks.
Thank you.
Okay, cool.
Thanks so much subscriber, longtime listener.
Appreciate your honest opinion.
I hope you have some happy holidays and thanks
for taking my call.
Thank you so much.
I appreciate it and great to hear from you.